bonsoir madame brière recevoir tout le
monde alors d'abord votre réaction est
ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est
bien vu là généralement bien reçu cette
annonce oui c'est bien c'est bien reçu
et on a consulté quelques membres de
notre communauté d'affaires j'ai bien
sûr qu'on voit que c'est un plan qui est
principalement pour le citoyen pour le
tourisme donc on encore quand même
quelques questions à se poser pour la
communauté d'affaires mais on va laisser
cette bonne nouvelle nous appuyer oui
bon il ya quand même quelques questions
si c'est un choix qu'a fait le
gouvernement là mais est-ce qu'on aurait
dû par exemple faire une place à la
coopérative tu règles dans le nouveau
plan
actuellement on a de la difficulté à
remplir les avions qu'on a déjà sur
notre territoire donc c'est un choix
d'affaires j'imagine que très que comme
autres projets au québec pour voir s'ils
sont si comme transportant ya de la
place pour un troisième transporteur on
parle bien sûr au gaspi pour le moment
nous notre notre intérêt c'est de
remplir les avions qu'on a déjà ici ne
serait ce que pour un avion rempli
toucheront moins moins dommageables pour
l'environnement que plein plein plein de
voitures qui font les grands le grand
voyage en gaspille montréal donc on
privilégie encore quand même de tout
supporter les transporteurs actuelle
mais dès que d'autres si le volume est
le père mais assurément qu'on peut être
d'autres transporteurs se joindre à me
laisser ceux ci on va de l'avant avec sa
madame brière c'est qu'on présume on
espère que la demande en descente risque
d'augmenter dans les prochains mois' que
les transporteurs aériens pourront faire
face à cette demande mais je pense je
pense que oui faut voir aussi son autre
main la conscience que ce qu'on vous
souhaite aussi en gaspésie c'est qu'on
est des transporteurs cinq audacieux
pour nous accompagner notre croissance
économique au public nous la cour de
gaspé on parle de gaspé madaghri grande
valley vallée cloridorme on est en
pleine croissance économique du jamais
vu même dans les plus grandes croissance
au québec donc on a besoin de
transporter sont toutes là dessus pour
nous accompagner la terre puis on est
aussi l'été on est déjà assez plein on
est heureux qu'ils aient plus de
tourisme nous ce concept de travail et à
ma position destination d'envergure
internationale au pied divers c'est à
dire avec tout les chic chocs avec
l'essor de la neige au podium le
potentiel avec qui va donc on sera tous
qu'on ne voit pas juste comme l'était
oui absolument et d'ailleurs dans le
plan on disait on va répartir les
billets en fonction de l'achalandage et
de différentes périodes de l'année donc
ça pourrait effectivement soutenir le
tourisme hivernal dans votre région et
les autres mais je veux revenir sur le
fait vous disiez l'enjeu madame brière
c'est de remplir les avions est-ce que
la diminution des coûts est suffisante
pour arriver à cet objectif là c'est un
dossier complexe on en arrive d'une demi
journée de travail justement avec les
éléments de la chambre de commerce le
prix est assurément et un est un
incitatif quand on sait qu on prend
notre voiture avec les prix de l'essence
sont à même de citations mais c'est tout
l'écosystème qui tourne autour de ça
quand on arrive ici pour qu'on ait des
voitures al oui il faut qu'on ait des
faucons et une panoplie de services
autour de la desserte comme tel et il
faut que l'expérience sera agréable pour
le moment on encore des défis assurément
de part et d'autre pour s'assurer que
tout l'écosystème autour d'un vol
simplement régional et est avantageux ce
qui fait que coop ce temps vote de gaspé
à montréal pour des soins de santé bien
là dans les transports en commun mais
c'est donc des cercles ça sera sûrement
regarder d'autres enjeux en fait parce
que là vous souligner l'enjeu du
transport lorsqu'on arrive à destination
mais y en a toutes sortes d'enjeux avec
la demande touristique on a vu en
gaspésie dans les dernières années il ya
déjà des enjeux d'hébergement qui ont
été soulevées de main d'oeuvre également
est ce que ça vient aggraver d'autres
problèmes ou de re problème si vous
voulez que vous avez dans votre région
je pense qu'on va voir un grand exercice
de communication avec nos intervenants
en tourisme comme tel on a déjà des
structures qui sont en place pour
prendre mieux communiquer on ne peut pas
arriver chez nous là comme il ya
plusieurs années un peu plus leur jeu
c'est espérer qu'on va pouvoir vivre du
vent et le sable on on demande à tout le
monde est responsable
et de réserver leur hébergement et de
venir chez nous on est toujours
accueillante mais c'est sûr qu'on a une
capacité une capacité limite pour ça
qu'on souhaite que travailler à
continuer à explorer l'automne le
printemps on a vraiment avec
l'engouement du télétravail tout le
monde au bout d'un peu de bonne notre
bonheur gaspésien donc assurément avec
la croissance économique convient
assurément la plus belle opportunité
pour venir vivre chez nous à une travail
télétravail est chez nous en dehors de
l'été donc vous courtisé plus que les
touristes si je comprends bien
parce que les saisons touristiques on a
vu les deux derniers étés on a
l'impression que c'était à pleine
capacité qu'est ce que vous prévoyez
pour l'été qui s'en vient si on prend en
compte l' annonce d'aujourd'hui qui
viendra ajouter à la demande va
assurément il va voir ça va être la même
chose que les années à l'elysée les
dernières il faut faire quand même
attention on ne fait de plus en plus de
bons exercices de communication 30 avec
notre organisation de tourisme gaspésie
on est beaucoup plus structuré et près
la législation aussi hélas les
municipalités ont pris ont pris acte de
certains certain laisser aller qui avait
sur nos plages ce don qui ont pu
encadrer un petit peu la législation
donc déjà là on peut à ce passé au
revoir des gens de façon des touristes
un peu plus bienveillant de notre
communauté notre environnement mon choix
je fais confiance au groupe toujours ce
fait confiance aux gros mais assurément
nous ce qu'on préfère c'est de pouvoir
continuer à travailler à étaler notre
saison c'est beaucoup plus agréable de
pouvoir vivre la gaspésie à toutes ces
saisons donc ces formations de notre
notre modèle oui madame brière l'appel
est lancé je vous remercie beaucoup
d'avoir été là merci beaucoup à vous
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit